this one equation will make you rich I
recently spoke at adworld if you stayed
at the very end you'll understand how
you can use the equation to sell lots of
stuff or lots of money and make yourself
unreasonably wealthy keep being awesome
and enjoy big picture there's two things
that I want to talk about one is how do
you create and sell valuable things
right you probably hear people say hey
like provide more value give value away
like it's all about value value but like
no one defines what is value what does
that even mean right what are the
components that create a more or less
valuable product or service the second
part is one of the four different things
that you can do to enhance value all
right so once you have a valuable thing
you can enhance it by adding scarcity
you can enhance it by adding urgency you
can enhance it by adding bonuses or you
can enhance it by adding guarantees and
you can also as a fifth half bonus for
you guys you can enhance the value by
simply naming it in a way that resonates
more with your avatar or the type of
person you want to sell to okay and so
if those are the five things that can
enhance the value of the thing that
you're selling if you have all five and
you do them well you will sell more than
you would if you didn't have them now I
won't have time to get in all five I'm
just going to talk about one of them
which is guaranteed it's a big picture
we're gonna talk about how to create and
Destroy value in the things that we sell
and we'll talk about how to reverse risk
through guarantees to make the things
that we are selling more compelling to
them because now they won't fear that
they're not going to get the outcome
that we promised cool awesome I spent a
very long time trying to figure out what
value meant and it's because I we worked
with a lot of portfolio companies and we
want to think about how we can create
new product offerings that are going to
be that are going to sell for lots of
money with big margins uh and make us
all rich right I wanted to come up with
an equation that would encapsulate this
so that we could basically formulate or
formulatically approach the problem so
it's like if we check these boxes we're
going to get something valuable then we
can just do this over and over and over
again and I had to do it that way
because I can't be the person who's
making the products in every one of
these companies at this point is I have
to create a process around it okay the
four variables are as follows so if
you're taking notes or you have
something on your side screen this is
the these are the writer downers number
one is the dream outcome is the thing
that we are promising something that
people actually want all right I'm going
to dive into each of these four in a
second but I'll just give you the four
and then we'll we'll double click all
right so that's number one and when
you're writing these down write it down
like a fraction so draw a line right in
the middle of your paper or whatever and
you'll have two on the top and two on
the bottom so number one is your dream
outcome number two is the perceived
likelihood of achievement How likely
does someone believe that if they
purchase your thing they're going to
achieve the outcome that we are
promising a lot of words hopefully a
simple concept number three is the time
component in essence how quickly are
they going to get the thing after they
pay the fourth is the dual-sided coin of
effort and sacrifice what does someone
have to start doing that they don't want
to do as a result of this purchase and
then what are the things that they have
to stop doing that they would like to
keep doing that they cannot no longer do
as a result of this purchase all right
so those are the four things and what
I'd like you to do in thinking through
this as we break it down is think about
your own products and services that you
have and think about how they Stack Up
in using this equation all right I'm
going to give you a big picture back and
forth example and then I'm going to dive
into each of them in more detail if we
were to think about an ideal outcome all
right so let's use weight loss because
it's an example that most people can
understand all right so why is it that
let's say you have some things that you
can sell for weight loss like fifty
thousand dollar surgeries for
liposuction and on the other hand you've
got a five dollar ebook that promises a
skinny tummy if they make the same
promise right which is the dream outcome
number one how is these two things are
so different in price right well it's
the other three variables right because
the dream outcome people want to lose
weight right and so that's unit number
one now the reason that that is number
one of the four is that if I were to say
hey I can make you a million dollars
versus losing weight most people many
men especially would probably value
making money more than they would value
losing weight not always but oftentimes
as a category investment things
franchise opportunities business
opportunities tend to sell for a higher
price which is the kind of the component
of B2B business to business versus
business consumer by and large when you
have two different things like that we
use the dream outcome to differentiate
entire Industries or category worries of
products as being more or less expensive
now once we have the same dream outcome
like weight loss being delivered then we
move on to the other three parts of the
equation let's go on to perceive
likelihood of achievement if I have two
people who are selling the same exact
thing let's use a doctor in that weight
loss example like the liposuction guy
and let's say that liposuction guy a
doctor has done 10 000 surgeries of
liposuction and let's say Dr B has done
one same surgery same dream outcome it's
going to take the same amount of time
same amount of effort for you this guy
might even spend more time on you than
this guy because he's not his
experienced which one are you going to
go with
probably the 10 000 guy why because of
the perceived likelihood of achievement
we have lower risk associated with
making this purchase because we believe
that if we give this money we're going
to have the outcome that we desire and
so if you think through this in terms of
your own products you're like am I doing
a good of job before the purchase of
increasing someone's perceived
likelihood of achievement because in a
very real way that confers itself or it
translates into higher prices this guy
even though it probably sticks it takes
him less time to do the surgery you
actually can charge more than this guy
isn't that wild so we've got the dream
outcome is the thing something people
actually want what's the perceived
likelihood of achievement now if we stop
there between making big promises and
making people believe that it's actually
going to happen for them that is what
the majority of young and new
entrepreneurs spend their time on most
people myself included spent the first
half two-thirds of my career trying to
beef up the top side I would promise
bigger and I would show more
testimonials more results promise bigger
more testimonials more results right
more third party identification more
celebrity endorsements Etc right but I
believe now now I've done this a little
bit that the actual fortunes rely on the
bottom side of the equation okay so
remember this is the top side that
creates value the bottom side of this
fraction are the things that destroy
value our goal is to increase the top
side and decrease the bottom side so
with time there's two components of time
we have the time delay between when you
buy and when you get and then the amount
of time to immediately start seeing any
kind of outcome so it's like the
experience along with so for example if
I signed up for a gym membership right
using this weight loss example I might
know that I'm not going to lose the
weight for a year but if I start seeing
value from the community I start you
know feeling more upbeat et cetera I'm
going to start experiencing benefits
that might not be my big goal but I'm
going to have other things along the way
that are going to still deliver value
quickly the whole component of time here
is how quickly between when I buy and
when I get I'll give you a B2B example
in a b2c example in a B2B example let's
say you own a marketing firm so this is
Admiral so I'm sure audit this will
resonate with a lot of you guys if you
have two agencies that are side by side
and they both say hey I'm going to do
some marketing for you and I'm going to
get your phone to ring one way or
another marketing agency a says okay now
that we're doing this you're going to
have to start you know recording lots of
ads for us and we're going to be meeting
three times a week an hour each time and
you're probably gonna take four hours a
week to record these these ads for us
and it's going to take us 60 days to get
this stuff done at day 60 your phone
starts ringing from the ads that they do
okay marketing age number two you sign
the paper and as soon as you sign the
paper and they process your credit card
your phone rings and it's a lead
within seconds
same product
time collapse and so one of the easiest
things I had a mentor once say this he
said one of the easiest ways to figure
out what product to sell is look at the
products everyone else is selling and
deliver the same thing in half the time
and so when we think about the products
that we sell is there a way that we can
condense TTV which is time to value and
so one of the key one of the huge ways
that we focus on when we bring a
portfolio company in acquisition.com is
we say how can we look at this this
Service delivery and see if we can do it
faster now before the people who are in
the room who are like well my business
is different we have a company that
publishes books for God's sake so a very
long process but what we were trying to
figure out because they're the same
situation where it's like it just takes
time for someone to like write a book
like how can we deliver this value
faster and so the thing is is it just
like that gym example that I said it's
not that you necessarily have to deliver
the longest result
first but you want to deliver a result
first you want to have a tangible
outcome that someone can experience
literally holding their hands and so one
of the things that they did was created
a little seven day kind of mini book
boot camp and when they did that people
at the end of seven days could have an
actual mini book published and live now
they make it clear this is not the book
that's going to make you a millionaire
but what it was was to break the belief
and to prove the concept that they could
really do it and then they got the bind
and really built the you know the real
book that was going to end up making the
money Etc right and so the idea here is
that if you are creative and if you are
a loser then don't think this way but if
you are a winner there's always the
question which is how can I make this
work for me all right and so you have to
think if like if you're a real estate
agent you're like well it takes 90 days
to sell a house how can you give someone
an outcome before that it's like well
what else happens they have to clean the
house they have to inspect the house
they have to they want to know about
ways to make more value there's Lawn
Care there's fixes there's a million
things that have to happen is there
other things that I can do along this
journey that I can provide more value to
this person earlier so they can get
better experience in a b2c example let's
say uh I'm on the internet and I'm
trying to buy something for weight loss
right it and I click the button that
says six minute abs and then six minutes
later I have abs how like literally I
look at my shirt like holy [ __ ] how
valuable
would whatever that thing be
if in six minutes I would have abs
probably infinitely valuable and so when
we can find ways to deliver the outcomes
to our customers sooner or faster they
will value it a lot more not just a
little bit more a lot more speed is one
of the best all-time competitive
advantages and so the last one is effort
and sacrifice so I said it's two sides
of the same point because when you take
on a new customer you have to have that
they have to start doing things that
they weren't doing before right that's
effort they didn't and they probably
don't want to do it because they weren't
doing it before which is why they don't
want to do it right and on the flip side
they've got stuff that they stop doing
that they do want to do right and that's
why they're two sides at the same point
in that market example I just gave with
the agency right let's say marketing
agency A and B and I said a had you know
you have to three three meetings a week
and you've got four hours to deliver us
copy and creative and whatever right
versus the other agency that's like oh
we've already tested all the stuff for
your industry and we've got
videographers and whatnot who can who
can already just start running the stuff
like you just pass and it's taken care
of how much more valuable is the guy who
takes none of your effort and sacrifice
takes no effort on your part to make
this outcome occur so if you're thinking
about this within your own business the
way that we like to think about these
four four variables right when we have
the effort and sacrifice the goal just
like time is to decrease it and if we're
repeating the same activities with every
one of our customers how can we
streamline that how can we predict what
that what is going to happen and how can
we how can we make you know three
onboarding calls into one and how can we
make one onboarding call into a
checklist so how can we streamline this
process such that it's seamless and
effortless and ideally immediate for
them to achieve the result all right and
so I said there's four four variables in
the value equation you've got a big
dream outcome that people want to
experience
they believe that the likely that
they're going to experience it is very
high the time that they have to wait
between when they buy and when they get
is as little as possible
and then the effort and sacrifice is
zero and when you put those four things
together you have a very valuable
product and so when I said that this the
bottom half of the equation is the more
valuable thing that as I've learned is
that a lot it's very easy to make bigger
promises and you know throw testimonials
and things like that it's much harder to
actually have the operational
effectiveness to drive results faster
and decrease the amount of effort that a
customer has to put forth and so the
competitive modes that exist in the big
businesses are on the bottom side of the
equation Netflix took over Blockbuster
because they made consumption of movies
and TV shows immediate and your effort
and sacrifice if you didn't have to get
up in your car drive around the corner
15 minutes walk around grab the thing
and then not to mention return it three
days later which is zero value add to
you right without getting your late fee
they just got rid of all of that so you
could just take your phone and start
watching but the actual dream outcome
and perceived likelihood on both of
those occasions that people thought they
were going to watch a movie or watch a
TV show and they're very certain they
wanted to do it right so like the top
side was the same the bottom side of the
equation is where they killed everyone
if you look at Amazon they made the
purchasing process seamless on two
angles if I can click with one button
and it comes tomorrow they made the
effort sacrifice virtually nothing in
terms of the purchasing and then the
time delay is virtually nothing in terms
of getting the thing and they continue
to shrink that time Gap they sell the
same products as everyone else literally
but what did they do they increase the
perceived likely of achievement by
adding all the reviews so people believe
that when they buy the thing they're
going to get the outcome they really
want the job they hired the product to
solve they believe they have when they
have that because of the reviews that
Amazon leaves right the time because
they get it immediately and it's and
they can buy it quickly and the same
thing with the effort and sacrifice
right and so that's ultimately how
Amazon is able to beat because they
provide value all right is this making
sense this is cool you guys digging this
okay I'll give you one cool benefit of
that four-part stack and then I'll I'll
segue into the guarantees portion all
right so I gave you four variables guess
what those four variables also equate to
they equate to headlines and copy so if
I want to promise something to a
prospect what am I going to say here's
the dream outcome here's a number that
is related to the amount of people
who've helped achieve this thing
here's how long it took them to achieve
that thing and then here are
stipulations around that claim and if
you have data from your customer success
Department which hopefully you do right
which is percentage of customers who
maybe leave a five-star review or
percentage of customers to achieve X
outcome by X date under this condition
now you have claims that you can use
that are very compelling in your
marketing and your copy these can be
headlines and emails they can be
headlines and ads they can be on your
sales Pages they can be hooks in in your
in your videos and creative content and
so when you think through these four
variables they are the consistent
variables of claims in general so when
you want to communicate to a
chiropractor that you can help market
for his facility you're going to say 70
of our chiropractors that we work with
achieve over 100 patients in their first
30 days without having to make an ad
effort and sacrifice and so when you do
something like that you use those four
parts of the equation that is also
reverse Engineers copy because they
should be related because value is what
people want to buy and so your ability
to persuade and your ability to
understand and communicate value
should be married when you're thinking
about your products and services and you
have these four variables you're like
okay how do I do this right so the way
that we think through this
is that we create a big list of problems
all right which is I like to think about
in sequence which is what is every
single mini micro step as chunked down
as humanly possible that someone has to
go through to experience this result so
if you're in the physical products
business then you're gonna that's why
Amazon spent so much time on the actual
purchasing because there's not a ton
that they have to do but once the person
uh receives the product what's their
first impression of the Box the
unpackaging the directions that that
they get in order to use it what the
using it experience looks like the first
time the second time Etc how can we
streamline that process for them how can
we give them different ways that they
can use the same thing right in the
services side there's probably a lot
more micro steps that somebody's going
to have to take in order to achieve the
outcome right and so the idea is we want
to write down every single problem that
could possibly encounter throughout
their entire Journey with us and then we
want to write out what the solution of
that would look like now we're just
putting we're in we're in fictitious
World here we're saying you know blue
ocean what would we do to solve every
one of these problems right and we get
this huge list a lot of guys who go
through the book have a hundred plus
different little mini micro problems and
many micro solutions that they have now
once you have this huge thing this is a
fun activity to do with your team is how
can we make the thing we sell more
valuable right once you have that list
you then do something I call the trim
and stack which is you look at that list
you say which of these is the most
valuable to them which is the one they
suffer the most from that is most
valuable them that's category number one
then next to those which of these would
cost us virtually nothing to to build or
Implement after we have a first time
experience right so it's like if you
have to build out like a grocery
calculator it's going to take you time
one time but then every time after that
it's done right what's the incremental
cost of each of these of each of these
Solutions and so then you order those in
terms of uh you I I just would go low
medium high it's very simple and so then
for me what we do with the companies we
have is we look at the things that are
high value and cost us very little to
provide on increment and we cut
everything else out and then we have
something that's extremely valuable and
costs us very low and that's how you
have a very high value very high margin
product or service that you sell that is
ultimately how we recreate value in a
business and we like to think about is
like what are all the capacities of the
business us what are all the problems
they could potentially solve and then
which ones will we choose to solve and
then once we're very ruthlessly clear on
the problems that we choose to solve we
cut out everything else and say that's
just not a problem we choose so we know
we could solve it but just based on the
economics of that solution or that
problem we don't want to be the ones to
do it and then we say ruthlessly focused
on things that we do we do more of it
okay now most people think that they're
selling against their competition
I disagree what you're really selling
against is inaction you're selling
against doubt you're selling against the
biggest obstacle which is risk the
comfort of not doing the thing or not
buying the product is so high we have to
help decrease their action threshold
right we have to lower that bar just so
they can just step right over it because
up here they don't want to take action
because it's too comfortable we have to
lower it so much so there's so little
friction for them to take action with us
that they buy I think one of the more
compelling things that a business can do
is offer guarantees all right guarantees
are you assuming a certain percentage of
the risk from the buyer whenever there's
an exchange between two parties there's
a certain amount of risk that both
parties incur and so if you have these
two parties and there's a certain amount
of risk that's shared you can shift the
risk in your favor because you have more
knowledge about the Fulfillment than the
client does why because you've done this
a hundred times before and this is their
first time and so it would make sense
that we shift some of that risk in our
favor and we do that in the form of a
guarantee rather than like insurance but
you can think about guarantees as
purchase insurance for the buyer and so
there are four ways that I think through
guarantees and creating and structuring
creative guarantees the four types are
unconditional guarantees which means it
doesn't matter what you do if you just
want your money back I'll give it back
to you that is the strongest type of
guarantee now depends on the type of
business if you can't offer it I think
you should because if you do the math on
if I reverse the risk and I get 20 more
sales because of this unconditional
guarantee and I get five percent more
refunds and not even five percent more
on an increment let's just say you get
five you go from one percent refunds to
five percent refunds which would be a
massive increase in refunds you still
added 15 to your sales and it was still
worth it mathematically that is why
having the guarantee is just a math
equation it's not like you can't let
your emotions be like well we got our we
got more refunds now it's like yeah we
also got 20 more sales so you just have
to think about it like that just be a
business person and not emotional about
it number two is a conditional guarantee
which is uh we will give you X if if x
happens y if this happens this is what
we will do right if y the next very
simple if you provide us content for our
marketing agency Always by noon on
Fridays before the ad campaign start for
the first eight weeks and if you don't
make at least twice what you paid us
over that first eight week period we
will give you your money back right you
can also say we will work with you until
you get your money back the third is uh
an anti-guarantee which if you don't
have a guarantee which there are there
are situations where that that makes
sense you want to lean into the fact
that you don't have a guarantee you
don't want to like not talk about it
because it's a normal part of the buying
process be like what are my assurances
like how do I know this is going to
happen you're making these promises how
should I believe you right and that's
where you lean in and you say oh no we
don't have guarantees and if you're the
type person that really needs a
guarantee this is not the program for
you because there's too much work that's
on your on your part we can guide you
but the vast majority of the success is
going to be in your hands we will guide
you but it's going to be on you and if
that doesn't feel good for you then
there's 100 other guys or you have some
sort of proprietary thing it's like once
I give you the super secret sauce you're
going to know it forever and so I can't
I can't give you a refund because the
day after you learn a secret it's not
valuable to you right and said for that
reason we can't we can't uh do any kind
of guarantees the fourth is what I call
implied guarantees so anything that's a
performance related offer you know we'll
increase your Revenue by X and we get 20
of the increase that is that is a an
implied guarantee to the buyer rev share
is profit shares uh performance bonuses
kickers doing things off of a strike
pricing going up all of those things are
implied guarantees based on performance
those are the four different things that
you can do in terms of guarantees now
the advanced version of this is that you
can stack guarantees so I can say I will
give you a 30-day unconditional
guarantee and I will give you a 90-day
conditional guarantee which means that
for whatever reason you're like hey I'm
not sure then you say listen the only
way for you to be for you to be sure is
for you to be inside the program because
I just want you to make an informed
decision you can't make an informed
decision until you've actually
experienced the product I'm just going
to give you a 30 day unconditional
guarantee so you can get in there
experience the benefits and then make
the decision for yourself it makes it a
very easy sale because then the sale
becomes essentially a trial now you're
going to close a lot more deals but
you're also going to get more refunds
but the netnet is you're going to to
make more sales and so you do the
unconditional guarantee and you say but
on top of that and this is where you get
clever is you look at the customers
who've made the most money if you're B2B
if you're b2c you look at the ones
who've gotten the result that you that
you promised the best results and then
you look at the client Journey that they
had what are the things they did who did
they talk to what was their experience
and so then what we do is we reverse
engineer their experience the key
Milestones of their experience and we
make those part of the guarantee so for
example if I were selling internet
marketing whatever then I would say as
long as you get your domain purchased
and you set up a website and you spend
at least one dollar in advertising or a
hundred dollars in advertising if you
don't get an Roi from this program by
day 90 I will give you your money back
and so we make two or three stipulations
that seem very straightforward but the
stipulations are the ones that we know
are the ones that drive client success
in so doing we basically guarantee that
they will succeed which is the point of
the guarantee and so we say listen if
you're trying to lose weight I will give
you two times what you paid me by the
end of this 90 days if you show up to
every one of the workouts and you send
me a picture of all your meals that's it
it you do that at the end of the 90 days
I guarantee that you're going to lose
you lose the weight that I promise
you're going to lose and so you just
look at what are the things in common
that the people who are the biggest
successes did and you just look at the
fewest common variables because the more
stipulations you add the weaker the the
guarantee is going to be I'll tell you a
fun one if you just want to get weird
um if if for some reason you have uh any
kind of like coaching or any kind of
business that's like that the compliance
of opening a Google doc and writing what
you're going to do that day and at the
end of the day just saying what you did
over I think it's it's like six weeks uh
is like one percent or two percent
compliance like people just can't do it
it's so simple if you want you could
just say hey here's my guarantee if you
just say what you're going to do and at
the end of the day you say what you did
for six weeks and you don't get the
results
then I'll give you the money back and
you automatically know that 99 of people
are not going to do that anyways so
anyways fun one for you guys one of the
things that people suck at with
guarantees is that they say they make
the guarantee amorphous they say results
guaranteed what you don't want to do is
say that because it's like Banner
blindness everyone's heard that before
and it means something different to
everybody what we want to do is spell
out exactly what our guarantee is and we
don't even need to use the word
guarantee we can just say
if you don't get very specific outcome
if you don't lose six inches from your
waist by this time period and you asked
I will write you a check for the
difference between what you gave me and
what you think it was worth you want to
spell it out in common language so they
understand what you're actually saying
rather than saying results guaranteed if
you enjoyed this stuff I have a book
called 100 million dollar offers you can
check it out it's 99 Cents I hope you
got a good return on your attention and
you can immediately use at least one or
two of the things to ultimately sell
more people at higher prices